while stargate universe really that bad
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
now i originally scripted this video i
wrote an entire post read it out on
camera and it just sounded so robotic
and fake that i'm just going to wing
this and i'm going to tell you my true
and honest opinions about why i think
stargate universe is actually a
masterpiece it's fantastic and hopefully
by the end of this video you'll agree
with me wait what
hey i'm sorry to interrupt matt but come
on i doubt it yeah well we'll see so on
the back of the final season of stargate
sg1 and the final season of stargate
atlantis stargate universe was born and
when it came out it was met with a lot
of critical reception because when the
show came out i also had a very
noticeable visual change it was a lot
darker it was a lot grittier and they
also had a much younger cast now a lot
of people didn't like the visual change
it didn't like the overall look and feel
of the show because it was very
different to how sg-1 or atlantis was
usually filmed it was a lot of handheld
camera movements it was noticeably
darker and there were even things like
sex scenes which had never been present
before in any stargate show it was very
apparent that this new stargate show was
very much tailored to a much younger
audience but i think it was actually
really ahead of its time in terms of
production value production quality and
even the stories that it told now
speaking of the visual change that sagar
universe bought being much darker and
much grittier it did match the overall
feel of the actual series as a whole it
was a very dark show it was a show that
was basically born out of the very idea
of what would happen if a bunch of
people who were just working on a
science project
found themselves in an impossible
situation where they couldn't return
home how would they react how would they
adapt and how would they work together
to achieve their goals the show very
much focused on the interpersonal
relationships between the crew and
really highlighted their struggles
because the crew that destiny didn't
have their own personal space they were
all very confined
little situations that popped up that
would just be a mild inconvenience to
you and me were actually blown way out
of proportion and that was something i
really enjoyed
seeing how these people reacted to the
situation they were in now that's
something i want to explore because the
change of pace the visual change the
much younger cast it had an overall
different feel to any stargate show that
came before it but that doesn't
necessarily mean it's a bad thing every
week we tuned in we wanted to see who
was gonna break who was gonna step up to
the plate and who was gonna be the next
villain because stargate universe didn't
really have a villain that's the beauty
of it it didn't have
the guar wall it didn't have the aura or
the replicators the villain was us it
was how we reacted to the situation that
we are in what would you do someone is
going to become the villain whether they
want to or not the situation you're in
you're going to adapt and that change in
circumstance can really lead a person to
become
what we would call the villain now
obviously stargate sg1 and stargate
atlantis did explore interpersonal
relationships i mean we had jack the
jack and sam from sg-1 will they won't
they the same kind of thing with taylor
and shepherd in atlantis but it was
expanded upon in universe it wasn't just
romantic relationships that we saw we
saw rivalries we saw the fear we saw
people scared for their lives now a lot
of people criticize target universe in
the fact that it was a very slow show
not a lot happened in the first season
and that's something i can agree with
but i believe it was doing a lot of
world building it was exploring the very
idea that these people shouldn't be in
this situation but they are and they're
trying to do their best we've got a much
clearer picture of what makes rush tick
we saw eli grow as a person and we even
had characters like sergeant greer who
was in jail for all intents and purposes
before icarus blew up
adapt to a situation where he had to
step up he had to
forget the fact that he was in jail and
try and become a leader so for me the
very first season of stargate universe
was very much let's put these people in
a situation they can't get out of let's
see how they react and adapt to this
situation and then we'll take the story
on from there and they did do that in
season two it got a lot more action
orientated in season two there were more
high stakes and
people who got that far
when watching it actually agreed that
season two was way better but it gets a
lot of flack just because the first
season was very slow and this is why i
think universe was very much ahead of
its time now when you have a look at
other shows that have been successful
a lot of them had really slow starts
take a look at breaking bad for example
the first couple of seasons were really
really slow because they were building
the world
they were showing you the relationships
between the characters showing the
changes that would gradually happen
and eventually they became like one of
the best tv shows of all time i honestly
do believe that if they gave universe a
chance they greenlit it for a third and
possibly a fourth season it would have
done way better
for that very reason if stargate
universe had come out today and it was
positioned alongside shows like the
expanse on the mandalorian and things
like that
it would just be commonplace the show
how it was filmed how it was framed
things like that is very very much how
shows are made today so in that regard
sgu was ahead of its time i just don't
think all users were ready for it people
wanted a sixth season of stargate
atlantis i also wanted a sixth season
but stargate universe was a completely
different show and i honestly don't
believe it deserved all the hate that it
got but what do you think let me know in
the comment section down below and if
you are new to the youtube channel make
sure you hit subscribe and press the
bell notification so you don't miss a
single video and also whilst you're down
there consider becoming a fully fledged
sidetracked member hit the join button
down below thank you so much for
watching
i'll see you next week
[Music]
you